there have been so many rumors and
reports going around about the new
Fantastic 4 movie but we finally have an
update from Marvel Studios themselves
the confirmed and announced director of
the Fantastic 4 film coming to the MCU
Matt shakman did an interview with
collider where they asked him a ton of
questions about the upcoming Fantastic 4
MCU film and he promises that this movie
is actually going to be quite different
than anything that we've seen the MCU
previously and of course we're going to
cover the entire interview but it does
seem like Matt shackman does seemingly
confirm that the cast for The Fantastic
4 is locked in ready to go and everybody
all the roles have been cast which means
some of those recent reports are most
likely true a lot to impack in this
interview let's get started but if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 and
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month so as I mentioned this is
an exclusive coming from collider they
did an interview with Matt shackman for
his upcoming Apple TV series Monarch
Legacy of monsters however they did Veer
off and ask many questions about the
Fantastic 4 and we're going to go
through the entire interview and tell
you exactly what he said collider Steven
wein trop asked the interview questions
and he asked about the upcoming
screenplay aka the story of the upcoming
fantastic for film in which Matt shakman
replied with this it's different in so
many ways I wish I could be specific I
wish I could say more but we are doing
things very differently from a story
standpoint from an approach to the film
making standpoint that really fits the
material I wish I could say more I would
love to but I can't but I think it's
going to be unlike anything you've seen
before and certainly unlike anything at
Marvel that you've SE seen before so
right away this sounds cool but it could
also be kind of concerning it can go
both ways a lot of things have worked
very well for the MCU up until now but
some could argue that recently things
haven't been as good as the first three
phases however Comfort is given by Matt
shakman when he talks about how much he
loves making this movie and about how
much he loves the characters and the
stories of the Fantastic 4 when speaking
about making the film this is what he
said I'm AB absolutely having a great
time it's a dream of mine to be able to
work on that speaking of the Fantastic 4
film I've loved those characters since I
was little it's such an awesome world to
be in the script is awesome the
characters are brilliant I'm super
excited I'm obviously very happy now
that the writer strike has resolved in
such a good way and we're able to
reunite with Josh fredman our amazing
screenwriter I'm really hoping for a
fair and Equitable resolution to the
actor strike soon two keeping our
fingers crossed but we're going we're a
snowball heading downhill it's awesome
it's got a lot of momentum it's really
fun so the way he talks about the movie
one seems like he has a ton of passion
behind the project two seems like he's
pretty knowledgeable about the Fantastic
4 since he's been fans of them and
reading their story since he was little
and three it sounds like everything is
simply going well with the entire
process right now with the screenplay
the story everything he says everyone
there is having a blast it's got a lot
of momentum and it's really fun so
that's excellent news he doesn't seem
concerned at all and it doesn't sound
like anybody else is concerned at all
and we know that this is Kevin F's
passion project so I'm sure he's very
involved with the process I'm sure he's
got a vision of his own and I'm sure the
vision of both of them is coming
together very nicely now the interview
goes on to reveal that next year they
are going to start shooting Matt shakman
said yes we are definitely going to go
in front of cameras next year probably
in the spring so Springtime next year
which really isn't that far away we we
might actually start to see set photos
that is typically what happens when they
start shooting stuff gets out which
means they should be announcing the cast
before then they're going to be filming
in London at Pinewood Studios now he
goes on to talk about two more really
important things one is the casting and
two is the VFX which has been a concern
lately with some Marvel fans thanks to
some Disney plus projects that Marvel
put out and unfortunately some movies as
well but he says some great things about
their process right now in great things
about announcing the cast soon we'll
talk about that but first big thank you
to hellofresh for sponsoring this video
many of you probably know by now that I
personally use hellofresh a lot because
for me it simply makes sense I have a
pretty busy schedule in my day-to-day
life and hellofresh just makes eating
good meals a lot easier for me with over
40 different recipes that I could choose
from each week hellofresh does all the
shopping and meal planning for you
ingredients arrive at your doorstep
pre-portioned and ready to cook along
with pictured step-by-step recipe cards
they literally make it as easy as it
possibly could be the meals are very
quick to make and they do include some
15minute meals as well it takes the
hassle out of meal time but it also can
save you money hellofresh is cheaper
than grocery shopping and 25% less
expensive than takeout that means less
stress of worrying about what you're
going to eat and you save money so if
interested go to hellofresh.com sl50
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's hello Fred
/50 Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for
50% off plus free shipping so going into
the announcement of the cast collider
asked obviously people are very excited
to know when you're going to announce
casting so when do you think fans are
going to find out information in which
Matt shackman said hard to say like I
said we're in the middle of a ag strike
and I'm keeping my fingers crossed that
they get a great deal really soon and we
can go back then
once that's resolved there will be a
plan at that point but I can't say too
much there will be an announcement at
some point I know that the internet is
very excited to find out and I'm excited
to share it I just can't do it yet so
what he says here at the end really does
make it seem like they have nailed down
the cast it sounds like they have their
cast and he wants to announce it yet
he's saying I can't do it yet due to the
actor strike which of course we totally
get however it does sound like deals are
done and if perhaps they cannot
officially write any contracts or sign
any contracts due to the SAG strike it
sounds like they probably have a
handshake agreement with their Fantastic
4 but his last couple of sentences there
I'm excited to share it I just can't do
it yet makes it really seem like he has
it and could do it right now if it
wasn't for the strike so I believe that
our Fantastic 4 has its official cast
Marvel first family has been cast we
simply have to wait a little bit longer
to find out who it is so let let's hope
that the sack strike and soon they are
supposed to be meeting next week but
we'll have to wait and see what happens
and like I mentioned the last thing that
he talks about is the VFX collider
stated and then asked one of the things
about Fantastic 4 is you have some
characters that have unique abilities
and I would imagine you have been even
while the strikes been on you've been
probably working with VFX companies to
try to develop those how is that going
to look on screen how has it been
looking at the effects for some of these
characters and finding the way you want
to breing these things to life and Matt
shackman said this we have been non-stop
despite the strikes yes we've been
working with the effects and with
production design and building our world
and that's been incredibly exciting you
know how do you translate those skills
into live action in Dynamic ways because
some things that work beautifully in
John burn and Jack Kirby are a little
tougher when you're filming them how do
you make sure that things are exciting
but also grounded in a scientific thing
which which is also part of the
Fantastic 4 that I love there's some
stuff I'm super excited about I can't
say too much you know so this is
fantastic news for a couple of different
reasons one is even though that they've
been shut down due to the strikes
they've actually still been working and
it sounds like they've been working
pretty hard which means the movie
shouldn't really experience any more
delays hopefully fingers crossed but two
it sounds like they really are putting a
lot of care and effort into the VFX of
how the Fantastic 4 are going to appear
on screen from Mr Fantastic stretching
to the thing to Johnny Storm's flame on
and of course our Su storm Invisible
Woman overall it just sounds like there
is a lot of care that is going into this
movie a lot of preparation a lot of
planning and after reading this
interview it makes me feel pretty
confident about the new Fantastic 4 film
that's going to come out now we've heard
that this film might take place in the
1960s and it might actually take place
in a separate Universe not our Earth
main 616 universe and that would
certainly make it it kind of a movie
with a unique story that hasn't been
done before yes we have visited other
universes in other movies but we've
never actually had a film from the
standpoint of a team from a different
Universe set in another universe so
perhaps that report is possibly true and
from what we have learned seems like
Vanessa Kirby is going to be our Sous
storm it sounds like Marvel Studios has
narrowed their choices of Mr Fantastic
down to Adam Driver and Matt Smith and
there was also a report that Joseph
Quinn from stranger things could be
playing Johnny Storm and for the thing
we have heard D Diggs and Ebon Moss
boxwatch although there hasn't been any
real solid information about either of
those names but that could be as close
as we can get to knowing our fantastic
forecast again it looks like Marvel
Studios has locked it down so let's hope
these strikes end soon so we can get an
official announcement they're going to
start filming in spring so we're
definitely getting an announcement
before then so hopefully not too much
longer hopefully they don't make us wait
until they start filming and spring in
the meantime let us know your thoughts
about all of this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
woof